he's leaving our plan worked we saved
our own honeymoon and fun bonus we
cheered up holt yes okay it's time to
celebrate you know what that means this
bee needs a c in her a oh my god this
babe needs a coconut in her arms oh
i thought you were saying this music oh
my god yeah that was my reaction all
right i'll go get us a couple of
coconuts and for all we know hitchcock
and scully have been playing us for
years like criminal mastermind
okay so maybe not masterminds but i'm
still going in there and getting the
truth all right guys let's not make this
any more difficult than it has to be we
know there was a fourth bag of money
where'd it go we told you dorks we never
saw it now leave us alone i don't think
you get what's happening here this is an
interrogation and it's only gonna end
one way with you telling us everything
something funny it's just i don't think
you get what's happening here you're
locked in a small windowless room with
the two of us one hour after lunch oh no
i want to know what we ate four cheese
pizza double cheese with a side of
cheesy fries extra cheese and a big old
slice of cheesecake but scully
you're lactose intolerant yeah this
whole room is a dutch oven yes that was
a delicious lunch gary and i agree our
group does seem happier than it was
before oh the pizza was that good pizza
right that's what i said we were getting
before we decided to a snazz it up oh
you guys snatched yeah we snazzed all
the way to le petit crippery i thought
we couldn't say snazz oh no i was
thinking we can't say carry on tell him
how good it was rosa tell him how high
our morale is
hi
wait
where is everyone
where are all the desks what is
happening what's happening is
you
[Music]
son of a [ __ ] stole my song
[Music]
wait terry has the bracelet that's right
me and my teammate terry one we fooled
you all you didn't do okay well neither
did jordan's teammates but they still
got rings all right fine just tell us
how you did it
ah that guy looks like he's wearing a
skin mask over his own face so i'm
guessing it's dr tate he has a normal
man's face jake yes he does have a
normal man's face stretched out over his
own face because he is a hannibal hi
there dr tate i presume yes hi nice to
meet you uh which one of you is in
charge and the mind games begin excuse
me sorry i'm detective peralta this is
detective boyle he's in charge dr tate
have you heard anything from mrs buckley
no i haven't and i'm quite worried i
received a frantic disturbing call from
james yesterday he was afraid he'd done
something horrible i asked him uh where
he was and he said he was in the park
near the zen garden i suspected he was
just experiencing delusions but when
they didn't show up for therapy today i
became very concerned so you think he
killed her and dumped her body in the
park sounds like couples counseling's
going really great for them sorry my
partner doesn't believe in therapy oh
that's fine it's hard for some people i
title your sex tape weak are you
normally so cavalier around murder
investigation uh yes we see a lot of
darkness in our line of work and humor
is one of our coping mechanisms it's
self-preservation through disassociation
it's something i've been working on with
my therapist
rosa are you stuck in there
no i'm in here by choice oh cause i hear
some banging noises as if someone was
struggling to open the door no that was
the pipes or is it the sound of you
learning how to ask for help you know
you can't spell independent without
dependent and you can't spell go
yourself without you
let's ask a dud damn amy i am loving
this shade on you the loot's right you
can't just fire somebody that said you
could inspire somebody to quit
for example broadway brian
yes broadway brian of course who the
hell is broadway brian brian in records
he's always talking about what a great
singer he is and how his dream is to be
in musicals you just need to convince
him to go for his dream i don't know
that feels underhanded it's never
underhanded to help somebody follow
their dream yesterday i was watching
ellen and she had this woman on who
wanted to be a chef but she didn't have
any taste buds so she quit her job hired
her best friend to be your taste tester
now they have the best taco truck in
lansing it was inspirational can we
please just kidnap cj now
[Music]
leave me alone leave me alone
you never get me alive help
[Music]
okay
hey could we stop and get a slushie what
are you doing you were gonna get
promoted out of missing persons your
plan went to hell tough guy once she
came to me with a much better one guess
what she's giving me for betraying you
my dream job captain of the 69th
precinct didn't go look you're not gonna
get away with this you were part of the
whole thing first of all jake there's no
records that you and i teamed up
together because you insisted that we
only communicate through a beeper oh
stupid beepers for right to be a dick's
door phones eyewitness all you your dna
is all over the scene and i caught you
red-handed making a hostage video your
is cooked that's not a saying it's goose
here's about a goose i'm talking about
cooking a penis who do we know that
could find us a random new york hot dog
guy
[Music]
so you need a little help from the
wiener warriors well i hate that just
tell us what you know please there's
lose dogs he serves him up real plus big
mikes does two dogs per bunch hank's
frank's great mustard selection vicky's
vegan i'd rather eat charlie doesn't al
dente dog it's got a really nice jew
johnny arkansas serves a little rock
style although he can serve it razorback
style okay enough enough we don't have
time for this
where am i
what is that table calm down you're at
the nine-nine and you know what a table
is i don't remember coming here how did
i get here oh my god
pimento has memento disease your memory
is resetting like the guy from the movie
memento
what you guys never saw memento it's the
guy with no short-term memory you know
christopher nolan's first movie is it
like dory from finding dory she keeps
forgetting where she's swimming no no
it's like dory yeah yeah yeah i'm like
the forgetful little fish well i mean
yeah it's like that but it's also like
just keep swimming that's what dory says
classic dory jake ugh you guys really
ruined the coolness of this memento
thing also jake following is christopher
nolan's first movie you sound like a
great apple out here
guys focus up we're all getting along
remember now we can't see the cake
before amy which means we have to figure
out a way to clean it up without looking
at it
we have to bird box it and bird box is
the bakery no bird box is a movie where
people aren't allowed to look at things
just put on these blindfolds and help me
clean it up like bird box the stewardess
and sweden ones dad
okay that should be all of it
i think it's safe to take off our blind
paw
what happened we were so careful here
comes the mop okay back
this is hard
i could use a beer
oh oh you okay you need to go to a
hospital right now i don't want a birth
happening around me it's way too gross
i'm nowhere near giving birth i haven't
even lost my mucus plug amy you need to
get out of here i'm sorry my baby
grosses you out rosa i'm excited to meet
your baby when it's clean and wearing
clothes and not blasting out of you like
some half cuban jimmy neutron i'm just
at the start of my labor i haven't even
had my first contro
[Music]
hey amy can we have a second no i'm kind
of in the middle of something you
oh yeah well
[Laughter]
yourself all right all right
you